[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen kraftfeld
meine lieben freunde
wir haben für die heutige wie so dass
zwei grosse teams und zwar sache nummer
eins wir müssen in das wüsten dorf gehen
denn ich benötige eine menge sand und
sache nummer zwei die wir mit dem ganzen
land an anstellen müssen ist in
unterwasser tunnel zu ende bauen
von daher würde ich sagen kräfte ich mir
erstmal ganz kurz noch zwei weitere
schaufeln denn ich werde auf jeden fall
mindestens 36 abbauen müssen
ich werde mir auch noch eine menge
glatten sandstein holen müssen den ich
benötige für unsere strandhaus villa
darum so der unterwasser tunnel sollte
ich auch schon längst auf jeden fall
benötige ich auch noch eine menge
glatten sandstein denn ich möchte den
glatten sandstein so ein bisschen hier
vorne noch umziehen denn hier kommt noch
etwas hin darum die sollte allerdings
nicht heute geben das wird nämlich den
rahmen sprengen sondern das wird in der
nächsten folge behandelt was soll ich
denn für euch tun
wahrscheinlich bei euch direkt vor
meiner strandhaus will an die
schildkröten auffangbecken
ich frage mich gerade warum ich nicht
einfach hier den sandabbau also hier
vorne ist ja unser leuchtturm dahinter
halt unsere inseln dann kann ich auch
einfach hier kurz unterbrochen muss sie
diese mittel stunde zum wüsten dorf
fahren
[Musik]
so da sind wir auch schon wieder zu
hause hier angekommen an unserer kleinen
fischerei heute hier vorne die noch nie
so richtig genutzt wurde irgendwie haben
wir auf dauer so viele sachen gebaut die
wie gar nicht richtig nutzen
wir waren noch kein mal so richtig in
unserem leuchtturm drin haben die
aussicht genossen auch die größe von dem
portal steckt überhaupt gar keinen sinn
die sache allerdings ist ich mir jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen kohle raus nehme
und bei ganz fix eben hier übersprintete
zu unseren höfen wenn ich werde ihn
sanft ich jetzt mal ganz kurz ein
bisschen aufteilen hier werde ich ein
bisschen reinpacken
hier werde ich ein bisschen reinpacken
hier werde ich die hälfte noch einpacken
zack und hier oben auch noch mal den
rest dann haben wir hier auf jeden fall
26 glas das benötigen wir nämlich noch
für unseren unterwassertunnel was ich
allerdings auch erst mal noch benötige
ist eine menge zu essen da bin ich ja
eigentlich immer so ein bisschen so ein
brot fern hier in minecraft die sache
ist nur dass ich fast keine weizen
sachen mehr habe um ihr brot zu machen
ich habe ganz ganz viele samenkörner
allerdings habe ich kein richtiges
weizen ich habe jetzt auch schon wieder
nur zwei im inventar vielleicht hätte
ich doch damals das feld hier behalten
sollen und nicht diese komische
situation
im wasser dann festhalten habe ich nicht
mehr daran so was ja nicht die ganze in
einem teich vorne kann nicht mehr so
er schwimmt raus das ist das zu schmal
oder was kommt er ist aber auch egal
sein darum sollte auf jeden fall nicht
jeden wir warten erst mal ganz kurz bis
das land hier vorne zu zu glas geworden
ist die sache ist jedoch dass ich noch
einige andere sachen benötige denn ich
packe dafür erst mal ganz kurz meine
sachen hier so ein bisschen sortierung
gemäss rein das weizen packe ich mal
hierhin drei weiter kann ich mir
zumindest mal ganz kurz noch mal so ein
brot mit machen
ich habe gehofft dass hinten bei der
farben zumindest die will ja mal ein
bisschen mitleid mit uns haben und auch
so ein bisschen sich darum kümmern dass
ich was zu essen kriege allerdings hatte
ja schon in der tat gerade gesehen dass
ich ein bisschen kicken sachen abgebaut
habe das hat ganz einfach damit zu tun
weil ich das für die nächste episode
brauche
und zwar hat das mal
[Musik]
wann ist der herr oben ich muss mir
jetzt jedoch erstmal einige andere
sachen mitnehmen und zwar die ganzen
antriebs schienen dann die restlichen
schienen die ich hier generell noch drin
habe werde ich auch mal mitnehmen und
jetzt bräuchte ich auch bräuche sprachen
lernen da hatte ich brauche auch noch
redstone blöcke denn diese redstone
blöcke müssen wir unter die aktivierung
bzw antriebs schienen sind ja die müssen
wir darunter setzen denn wir können
nicht richtig unter wasser mit rats und
fackeln arbeiten
ich weiß ich habe jetzt gerade noch
nicht genug saß um den tunnel hinten
ford ford zuvor zu was für vorstellen
dicker diese ganze vorproduktion für
meinen urlaub macht meinen kompletten
wortschatz kaputt es sieht schon sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr geil aus mit
dieser insel hier vorne und das ist dann
hier untergeht und dann fängt es an mit
dem wasser und klar jetzt gerade stoßen
die ganze zeit noch den kopf online
ich muss hier erstmal noch alles zu
bauen
ich brauche unbedingt diese schwämme bis
sich die schwämme allerdings habe aus
dem ozean moment werde ich das ganze
erst mal mit skis machen die sache ist
dass die sonne jetzt auch schon wieder
untergeht von daher gehen wir auch mal
ganz fix eben schlafen können vorher
noch mal eben kurz hier ein bisschen
glas rausnehmen zack-zack damit sollte
es auf jeden fall möglich sein glaube
ich den rest des tunnel zu bauen
die sonne hat noch nicht ganz das wasser
erreicht erst dann können wir ins bett
gehen das sollte allerdings jetzt
passend der fall sein perfekt schaue
hier schön rüber zudem scharf und der
kuchen können uns jetzt komplett in
unterwasser tunnel kümmern was ich
dahingehend auch noch machen wollte und
das wollte ich eigentlich erst am ende
machen allerdings laufen wir jetzt geht
noch mal dran vorbei von da habe ich mir
gedacht wenn ich jetzt auch einfach
vorher machen denn dann hab ich noch
mehr ansporn das ganze heute wirklich
fertig zu machen denn ich möchte das
ganze jetzt auch hier von unserem
schwarzen bretter unternehmen da steht
jetzt nur noch dann die stranden muss
fertig gemacht werden und die hundehütte
die unterwasser tunnel heruntergenommen
er ist völlig fertig mit dem machen wir
wirklich heute fertig die strandvilla
möchte ich in einer der nächsten folgen
auf jeden fall auch noch fertig machen
das gibt es ein paar projekte die ich
einfach noch abschließen möchten bevor
ich dieses ganze projekt die abfolge 100
abschließen und heute kümmern wir uns
erst mal um diese unterwasser tunnel
also jetzt hier überall keaton setzen
zack
und jetzt können wir das ganze nicht
vorne einfach wieder abbauen
[Musik]
so dass wir sind jetzt die letzten
stücke die ich hier gerade hingesetzt
habe die sache allerdings dass jetzt das
wasser natürlich wieder ein fließt
allerdings nur bis hier vorne hin also
der rest hier ist auf jeden fall trocken
und jetzt kann ich auch mein glas nehmen
und den tunnel hierzu ein bisschen zu
ende bauen dann gehe ich jetzt nämlich
hier einfach weiter vor
zack zack zack zack zack zack und dann
hier drei blöcke hoch je drei blöcke
hochgeht blöcke hoch das gleiche dann
auch noch mal auf der anderen seite so
dass das ganze dann schlussendlich so
aussieht und wir hier dann an der stelle
den fähig so ein bisschen nach oben
bauen können mit dem glas beim und haben
dann haben wir glastunnel jetzt auf
jeden fall schon mal fertig ich kann
auch mal ganz kurz die eben von der
anderen insel schauen ob das hierzu
alles passt das sieht allerdings gut aus
jedoch müssen wir jetzt hier natürlich
wieder runtergehen und das ganze mit dem
keystone ein bisschen zu bauen weil wir
einfach wie gesagt die schwelle noch
nicht auf dem kurzen moment holt haben
jedoch müssen wir generell in der
nächsten folge noch mal im moment gehen
denn ich benötige noch ein paar seele
hat herrn und das hat auch etwas mit der
nächsten folge zu tun das wird mich
heute wie bereits gesagt den rahmen ein
bisschen sprengen hat jedoch mit unserer
strandhaus wetter zu tun nicht ob der
eine oder andere der bei diesem projekt
bisher komplett schon mit dabei ist der
weiß auch bescheid was mein ziel mit der
strandhaus wieder sein wird jedoch euch
nochmal eine ganz kurze time life macht
keinen sinn
details ist eine sache von einer minute
das jetzt ganz kurze ende bauer sowie
letzten blöcke hier noch kurz abbauen
und dann haben wir hier auf jeden fall
einen furz trockenen tunnel am start
die sache ist jetzt allerdings sind dies
benötige ich nicht mehr glas benötigen
auch nicht mehr also der restlichen wir
hinten im ofen haben das eigentlich
relativ unnötig die frage ist jetzt die
allerdings wo wir die antriebs ihnen
hinsetzen denn die sache ist dass wir
hier vorne direkt haben ich glaube was
soll ich denn hiervon abstand 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 hatte ich immer als abstand
ich glaube dass auch noch beibehalten
also 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 dann will ich
jetzt nämlich diesem blog hier abbauen
und ersetzen durch einen redstone block
und dort eine andere schiene darauf die
ist nämlich automatisch gebaut so dass
wir hier an schwung bekommen dann hier
wieder 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 hier vorne
den blog auch abgebaut und eine rats am
block hin und hierfür die antriebs
schiene gehen wir wieder 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 bauen hier wieder ganz kurz dem
blob das blöde ist dass ich jetzt halt
die ganze zeit einfach meine diamant
spitzhacke benutzer und die hat ja
leider die verzauberung behutsamkeit
deswegen müsste ich glaube ich einfach
kurz fitschen sowie reisen spitzhacke
also wir 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
dann wieder ganz kurz tauschen ich weiß
nicht ob es nacht wird oder warum sitzt
sie gerade bisschen abgedunkelt wurde
allerdings auch ich habe die verbraucher
angenommen ok 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
hier vorne noch mal eben kurz abbauen
einen blog in bar und nochmal 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 die sache ist jedoch dass mir
eine menge leute auch in die kommentare
geschrieben haben luca du kannst mir
darunter noch im block setzen mit einer
fackel dann hast du nicht alle paar
blöcke sowas rotes allerdings habe ich
das ja auch oben so dass wir alle blöcke
was rotes haben deswegen finde ich das
eigentlich auch ganz gut wenn sich das
hier wieder findet die sache ist jedoch
dass ich das auch probiert habe so zu
machen dass ich einen
block hier drunter setzt mit einer
rettung fackel und blablabla musste ich
halt hier oben hin
er muss sich daten darunter quasi wieder
das war kein wasser hin kommt für die
red storm fackel
das ist dann immer ein bisschen stressig
gewesen deswegen habe ich mir jetzt
gedacht wo es ist auf jeden fall ein
bisschen einfacher hier vorne entferne
ich das auch noch mal ganz kurz so dass
ich hier vorne einen blog in sätze für
die antriebs schiene dann haben wir auch
wieder zehn blöcke abstand und dann hier
wieder 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 ja ich
glaube das sollte passen also der
unterwasser tunnel ist eigentlich mehr
oder weniger fertig wir haben hier die
ganzen sachen gebaut über die redstone
blöcke wir haben die antriebs schienen
da hinten geht es wieder hoch das ist
alles trocken das glas ist am start
ich habe es auch schon lore mitgenommen
dann können wir das ganze jetzt direkt
neben testen und mal eben schnell dort
vorne hin laufen das wird dann jetzt
einfach die erste fahrt im unterwasser
tunnel
ich bin ein bisschen gespannt also das
hier ist ja unser bahnhof und da können
wir jetzt einfach mal dass katia
anschieben bzw die lowe nochmal ganz fix
und wir steigen ein und es geht los
also wir fahren auf jeden fall auch bei
einem guten tempo ich glaube dass es die
gleichen geschwindigkeit wie wenn ich
mit dem boot fahren würde allerdings
muss ich halt nichts machen nicht lenken
okay das hat alles geklappt das hat
alles geklappt wir können uns links und
rechts um gucken und sind quasi unter
wasser hier sind hinten fische
korallenriffe alles mögliche beleuchtet
und jetzt geht es hier vorne wieder hoch
und wir fahren weiter in richtung
festland ich hoffe mal dass alles klappt
und dass da hinten vernünftig ankommen
eigentlich müssen wir dann da ganz vorne
also dort hinten dann ordnet
vernünftiges was steht da
ach der ist im kart von uns ich habe mir
zwar irgendwie gedacht dass wir öfter
hier sein werden allerdings war es doch
nicht der fall wird es das ganze noch
mal in die andere richtung also ab 1
gestiegen und losgefahren hier vorne mit
den fischen hinten geht die sonne hinter
unseren kleinen feldern unter ace schon
wundervoll also schlussendlich klar ich
hatte mir vorgenommen in unterwasser
tunnel komplett über die komplette
distanz zu machen allerdings wenn ich so
eigentlich auch ganz schön
dann haben wir so ein bisschen so eine
kleine strecke die er übers wasser geht
und dann wissen wir schon okay es geht
rein zu unseren inseln
denn wir fahren ja hier vorne schon beim
zittert er so hatte angst weil sie jetzt
runter gehen wo man jetzt auch nicht
mehr
das waren wir hier auf jeden fall unter
wasser her quasi schon geil aus wenn ihr
alles beleuchtet es mit den
korallenriffen und so und dann fahren
wir schlussendlich wieder hochkommen aus
der anderen insel draußen sind quasi
wieder in unserer welt ich bin schon
happy das war eines der projekte wo ich
gedacht habe dass wir das niemals fertig
kriegen in diesem ganzen minecraft mit
luca projekt in jetzt haben es einfach
geschafft
es ist nacht
[Musik]
ja was hat er denn für rüstung an
ich habe auch immer schließt davon
abgebracht immer schiss dass von
irgendwo noch ein kluger so oder so von
hinten kommt weiter ist niemand mehr
glaube ich okay wir gehen wir ganz fix
eben nach oben ich kann nicht mal mehr
sprinten haus da sagt okay wir können
schlafen meine lieben freunde
wir haben es geschafft dass hier was ich
mir für heute gesetzt habe und zwar die
erste fahrt so richtig im unterwasser
tunnel zu machen klar dass wir hier
direkt noch einen haben und leute dabei
wächst hier nicht mehr haben uns auf der
insel uns lange genug mit bauen
beschäftigt ich werde jetzt auf jeden
fall meine lieben freunde noch mal ganz
fix da hinfahren ich werde jetzt auch
mlg trick schott machen aber ganz kurz
hier los ist
[Musik]
in der kritik
china hält es jetzt ohne uns durch den
ganzen unterwasser tunnel ja entspannt
der keeper ist weg da wollte ich mich
eigentlich gerade außen mein karthaus
töten mit meinem pfeil und bogen
allerdings meine lieben freunde würde
ich an der stelle
die heutige episode minecraft mit luca
jetzt auch beenden wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann das kann einen daumen hoch
unter video hier da abonniert main kanal
und in die nächste episode nicht
verpassen wollte kickt selbst
wahrscheinlich auf die glocke dann
bekommt eine benachrichtigung sobald ich
nie hochladen in der nächsten episode
wird jetzt sich wieder ein wenig um
unsere strandhaus villa drehen denn ich
möchte etwas bauen was hier vorne hin
kommt ich möchte das mit dem glatten
sandstein außenrum ein bisschen anders
machen
also schaltete auf jeden fall gerne gibt
es auch richtig wie heißt ich da
[Musik]